Wake up your sweet tooth with the chocolate
for breakfast bar set that’s baconluxious.
And write down your to do list on this piggy
bank made out of postit notes.
Because it’s episode 49 of LÜT.
Carry sun power on your back with a Voltaic
solar backpack. That features a solar panel
and battery designed to transfer a few hours
in the sun into a fully-charged smartphone.
And the fabric is made out of recycled soda
bottles with waterproof backing to protect
your devices.
Devise some beats from your pants using a
pocket drum machine. Teenage Engineering’s
pocket operators series features the battery
operated drum machine, bass synthesizer and
a lead synthesizer. They each have 16 different
sounds and effects to make stuff on the go
like this…
Monitor the circadian rhythm of your newborn
thanks to the Mimo Smart Baby Monitor. A machine-washable
onesie that tracks breathing, body position
and sleep status and sends the data to your
smartphone so you can finally get a good night’s
sleep on your Ostrich arm pillow.
The Valentine’s Day Mystery Box is filled
with I don’t know and neither will she!
Or he. Or Cthulhu plush.
Unicorn bouquet. That replaces roses with
the magical gift of unicorns each on their
own stem that’s detachable.
Attach these overly-complicated wooden light
switches that use gears, rack and pinion,
toggles and levers that are installed over
the existing plastic covers.
Cover yourself and some friends with the world’s
largest underpants.
And have the world’s most famous lake monster
stick its head out of pans when using the
Nessie Ladle.
Roller Tape.
Clone your pets in the cuddliest way possible
by ordering a customized plush replica from
Cuddle Clones.com. Just upload some pictures
of your four-legged companion and in a few
months you’ll have your stuffed Dragon.
(Draggin’) around ice cold beverages is
easy with the IceMule. A portable cooler that
keeps contents cold for up to 24 hours and
can be easily rolled up and stored when not
in use.
Use Key Kong to hold onto your keys so you
always know where they are.And all Key Kong
asks for in return is...
Just don’t take me for granite.
The TextBlade doesn’t take touch-typing
for granted. At just one third the size and
weight of an iPhone it provides the same full
finger spacing of a desktop and sets itself
up magnetically. And the battery lasts about
a month per charge.
Get medieval in your writing after having
a pen bestowed by a bowing knight.
Or bring night into the future with the Leeo
Smart Alert Nightlight. Not only can you set
its brightness and color it has an ambient
light setting to turn on when the lights get
low. It listens for smoke alarm and carbon
monoxide alarms and monitors temperature and
humidity and then alerts your smartphoneif
anything is amiss.
Feel free to miss your mouth when wearing
a hydrophobic t-shirt from Threadsmiths. The
100% cotton shirts contain no chemicals and
are crafted with a patented hydrophobic nanotechnology
that repels water and dirt. And syrup. And
as always - thanks for watching.